Andrew Freedom At Last
it's funny he has his hair now and I
don't have mine are you gonna dope
it's a little bit emotional I've been in
one room since last year so uh it's a
little bit emotional I want to give
respect firstly to the judges who hurt
us today because they were very
attentive and they listened to us and
and they let us free so I have to give
absolute respect to them how crazy is
that that after you were locked up for
over three months the first message
that's out there is that you're giving
respect to the judges that's wild
gentlemanly that is I have no resentment
in my heart for the country of Romania
or for anybody else I just believe in
the truth it was political so I believe
in God and I think that the fire of
truth will eventually destroy all lies
and anybody who lies on a long enough
time frame will feel the sting of regret
and I believe in this yeah sure
um I I truly believe that Justice will
be served in the end there is zero
percent chance of me being found guilty
of something I have not done I maintain
my absolute innocence and I think most
people understand this and uh I look
forward to uh being home so thank very
much everybody so is is the
investigation still going on yeah
they're under house arrest I was just
about to say like they're not free like
they're under house arrest which is
crazy but people are so happy that
they're at least out of prison and they
know they're safe yes he can be home be
with his family now get a haircut live
it's so wild like not prison food the
three months of this Tate stuff has been
crazy like At first people thought that
he was they didn't know if he was in
jail or not because he was still
Tweeting and stuff so people thought it
was maybe just home or something like
that and then he had like cancer
apparently it's been really crazy
so many different times where the the
judges have had to um there's been like
big decisions whether he's gonna stay
for an extra 30 days there's a protest
that was coming up like an interesting
it felt long for us with him in jail
three months I can't even imagine how
long it felt for him what have I even
known about him for nine months before
that that's crazy three the last three
months he's been locked up it's
mind-boggling like thinking about back
to something that you did three months
ago like what did you do on New Year's
because it was right before New Year so
what did you do New Year's imagine since
that party you've been you've done a
million things yeah like we've done a
million things both of us it's really
it's really sad I hate the thought of
people being incarcerated innocent
people what are all these what are all
these influencers going to do now that
they're they're so happy that Tate was
in jail and if he's proven innocent are
they gonna go back and be like you know
what I was I was wrong you know an
innocent man being in jail for for three
months is wrong and that's on me or are
they just gonna keep the Tate hate going
they'll just keep they hate going it
doesn't matter people make up their
minds and they cannot admit to being
wrong and again like we've supported him
but I've said all along we haven't seen
the evidence we don't know he's not God
he's a guy but I will continue to say he
is innocent until proven guilty period
yeah period I would treat anybody that's
what like everybody was saying like if
you actually showed us like some proof
for evidence or even charged him with
something like there was nothing there
was literally nothing we all knew we all
knew the true reasons for them going
after him yeah it was it's a crazy thing
it's been really and honestly I mean I
even just tweeted I said there's been an
energy shift since he's gotten out which
I truly do believe because having him in
there speaking the truth it it almost
felt like like a cap that was there like
you can only maybe maybe this is a bad
way to put it but like I don't know it
it sucked because like this guy speaking
the truth is now being punished for it
so so many other people were now
starting to become afraid but not seeing
him out there again it lit a fire in a
lot of people I could really tell and a
lot of people had they walked
differently well I hope you're right but
you know former president Trump was
indicted and I haven't seen the
indictment yet it was today yeah so I I
am really curious to see what the the
charges are but it feels again like kind
of a Witch Hunt the way this felt it's
crazy you know and um well you know a
lot of people are saying that that's
what it is and even people who don't
like Trump are admitting that it appears
to be politically motivated and it's a
great way to keep him out of the race if
he wasn't running again this wouldn't be
happening so you know watching you know
one person who we we've seen be
persecuted without evidence The Matrix
you know come out and another person you
know going into the system Trump isn't
in jail he's in he's at Mar-A-Lago just
a couple of yeah a little up the road so
he's going to have a better experience
but it could it could get really ugly
and it's really frustrating he's a sex
trafficker yeah that girl I mean one of
the girls that you interviewed on the
street said she wanted him to die I hope
he dies [__] you too okay another one
was
um she she said he should go back to
jail all and they they had no hard
evidence on anything how could you wish
that somebody just got rot in jail when
they when they may be innocent because
you saw a couple of Clips on them on the
Internet like God help that girl may she
please wake up and and come to reality
and come to God and be a better human
being and be kinder to people that's a
terrible way to live with that much hate
in your heart thank God we have fetchy
we live in a society where everybody's
supposed to be gay I don't know that I'm
thanking God for fat G yet I haven't met
him we're meeting him soon but that's
gonna be maybe I will thank God for
patchy but not yet fat she's the real G
it's a big G all right we don't know him
that well so let's not followed his
altar hmm just joking around bro he got
massive my God yeah he did get bigger
how do you bulk in jail he looks even
more serious
everybody folks in jail
it's nothing else to do
I don't like his house why it should I
just it I mean it's it's it's divine uh
but because it just looks it's dark and
batman-ish it feels like no it doesn't
it it it's not warm and welcoming it's
just a style I don't I don't like I
don't like him any less because of his
house it's just not a style a place that
would want to hang out very nice no no
thanks I think it's cool I like the
Batman type feel I think it's dope the
No Light No Windows Darkness okay I'm
saying the No Light No windows but I
think it's I don't know yeah it's like
it's like a club that doesn't feel homey
to me he has children I wouldn't want to
be a child in that house it's scary his
children are growing up in like
Kazakhstan they're running and they're
running with Lion somewhere what that's
what he said he said he's his boys he
wanted some growing up in the mountains
nice good for him through struggle pain
anything else you want to talk about no
I'm just glad he's out and uh what about
Tristan have there been any words from
Tristan no not not on video I did notice
the one tweet that somebody said is he
Morpheus as hemorphous now on or
something no no look at this on Twitter
Tate just liked one of my recent tweets
and you clowned before it which one did
I clown you for you say something I pray
to God this girl breaks my heart so I
have more fuel fuel to turn into a
superhuman okay like this and you came
in with the hate usual it's not hey give
me the palm the face palm
how is that ridiculous because that okay
the fuel to turn into a superhuman is
already in you and if you you have to
learn how to dig for it without getting
your heart broken it's there so figure
that out and find it if you we keep
looking into ourselves and looking to
the outside world for this girl to break
my heart or this to happen so that I can
find the strength to do this you're
always going to run out of strength
you've got to turn you you gotta you
gotta find God kid yeah you do no says
says God and your mother I agree I agree
no because you never run out when you
turn to God you never run out of that
fuel to turn into a superhuman it's a
good point you don't need anything from
the world to happen to you and you
certainly never going to find it just in
yourself well you know it's not super
legit I'm not literally sitting there
praying that this girl breaks my heart
but I I don't know the point of it was
that if you do get your heart broken to
transfer that energy into good and to
not let it destroy you that's kind of
where and I think that's a great Point
that's kind of the message that I was
trying to convey there because I
remember even back like I've said this
before I had success I wanted a girl to
break my heart or so like life was going
too good life was going too good I was
like I need some some horrible [__] to
happen and then yeah my friends screwed
me over and then that was kind of like
set me even on a straighter line to
success so I don't know yeah we do have
that fuel inside of us but sometimes if
you have a little quicker match or a
little butane and you blast it it's not
always the worst I would also just say
be careful what you wish for you know
because you you can wish for one thing
and and get something that is so much
different and so much harder than you
expected so you can say oh man I wish
for some bad [__] to happen so I can
find my fuel or you can be grateful that
you don't have bad [__] happening yeah
both good points I'd say all right thank
you so much for watching make sure to
like subscribe follow me on Instagram
and I'll see you later
oh my
oh my God
[Music]